for a while you called the NFL the
no-fun league yeah because you had some
great moves they might have fined me for
this you know we won't find you for that
all those cookies now you got a check
for me no no no fun league because you
like to celebrate in the end zone you
like to celebrate when you had a great
run with grabbing yourself in a certain
area I don't want to get too vulgar hmm
I don't want to you know get too nasty
so did you mean like you talked about
grandma ding-ding sauce what what do you
call grandma ding ding sauce oh man
[Applause]
like grandma into this to talk about
anybody you know my grandma like you so
I know she want mama I apologize for him
right now worked in years
listen let's see ok grabbing the
ding-ding sauce yes yes I apologize to
grandmothers everywhere Andy Andy you
heard the same thing I did I did your
grandma ding and I'm not even heard I
thought he was just confessing to being
prematurely gray in a
[Applause]
the powerful one
[Applause]
they did not like it when you would grab
the ding-ding sauce and it failed on
like a lot of stuff they don't like a
lot of stuff you know now you're out in
the world you can do whatever you want
you can like if if you're if there's no
line at the at the restaurant at the
Olive Garden you get right up to the
head of the line and you want to
celebrate you can grab the ding-ding
sauce I mean I mean I could do it right
here no no I've got to stop that my bad
it's a problem my bad my bad
[Laughter]
you